you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
two weeks of climate protests begin as
extinction rebellion take to london
streets demanding an end to investment
in fossil fuels
flash floods and record-breaking
rainfall hit the u.s state of tennessee
and could hydrogen hold the key to green
steel
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
extinction rebellion have kicked off two
weeks of protests by using a giant pink
table to block roads around leicester
square in central london the
environmental campaign group say the
disruption will continue until the
government agrees to stop all new fossil
fuel investment immediately
skies ashna hurinag is at the protest
and has the latest well this marks the
first day of two weeks of action that
we're walking through at the moment a
crowd i'd say about a thousand or so
moving from trafalgar square going up
towards those big institutions up in the
city one of those that's joined us on
this march today is sophie sophie thanks
so much for talking to me talk to me
about why you're here the importance of
taking action today um i'm here because
i want to listen and uh respect the
planet i believe that we need to cut
down on fossil fuel usage and stop
extracting fossil fuels i'm also here as
a mum
and i'm here for the future of my kids
and i'm here for the future of
everybody's children
we all have a right to be here
and we need to believe that trees have a
right to be here that the bees have a
right to be here and we need to protect
everybody we need to tell stories about
the future and those stories have got to
be hopeful and at the moment they're not
they're absolutely depressing and as a
storyteller myself i'm here because i
feel that
i need to shout to people that there is
a possibility there is a future there's
an imaginative a collective imagination
right here on the streets of london
today and it's going to carry on for the
next two weeks why is it important to
you that the fossil fuel investment from
some of these big companies stops now
why is that the immediate action that's
being called for i think it's essential
because it's so short-sighted it's a
small-term gain for a long-term pain and
that's a real problem for the future of
our planet thank you very much well the
march is likely will continue throughout
the day there is no such plan as such of
where those protesters will end up but
we don't do know that they will be
occupying some of those big spaces in
london but particularly those financial
institutions the bps the shells of this
world they of course have their hq's
right here in the city of london and
that is where the protesters want to
make their voices heard the most
and you can read more about the
extinction rebellion protests the
controversy surrounding them and what
the government is doing to reduce
investment in fossil fuels on our
website skynews.com
climate
parts of tennessee have been devastated
by flooding after record-breaking levels
of rainfall hit the u.s state more than
20 people have died and numerous homes
were swept away after flash floods this
weekend well the area was hit by lines
of storms for hours resulting in a
record amount of moisture a scenario
scientists have warned may become more
frequent due to global warming well up
to 17 inches of rain fell in less than
24 hours shattering the state's record
for one day rainfall by more than three
inches according to the national weather
service now flash flooding in the city
of waverly 60 miles from nashville took
out roads telephone lines and even swept
away homes
while nbc correspondent sam brock is
there so sam just how unusual is the
extremity of this weather and what's the
situation like there now
anna it's good to be with you extremely
unusual it's not that this part of the
united states doesn't see flooding it
certainly does especially this time of
the year what's unusual is that there
was a flash flood warning and then
neighbors as they describe it to me saw
homes storage units and swimming pools
just floating through their
neighborhoods the creek where this all
came from at least in this part of
waverly anna is over my shoulder right
here it looks nice and docile right now
there was so much rain water as you very
articulately put just a second ago the
17 inches which is a historic level that
it came up from over there washed over
the lot that i'm standing on went across
the street and reached the porch level
of the homes next door one 69-year-old
woman that i interviewed said she had to
be picked up and carried away the water
on the other side past where those trees
are went out onto the highway a quarter
mile away that's pretty extreme we say
that it moved homes over here this is
the foundation of what once was a home
there that home is actually if you look
up right over my shoulder twirled around
360 degrees and now sitting on the bank
of a river next to that there's a series
of homes all juxtaposed together one of
them anna came from across the street so
you talk about the historic precedence
of this kind of thing back in 2010 there
were bad floods here in this part of
middle tennessee but from what i'm told
here the neighbors say they said it was
a thousand year plan then
we're 10 years removed and now we're
seeing something that is even worse is
that due to global warming is it the
amount of moisture that is in the
atmosphere right now hard to say but we
are seeing more events in the united
states and certainly across the globe
germany comes to mind where there are
flood events that are breaching levels
that had not previously been thought
possible but that's what's happening
right now anna
sam thank you well the flight in
tennessee aren't the only extreme
weather events in the united states at
the moment there's been flooding in new
york and new jersey after storm honoree
made landfall on sunday over 140 000
homes lost power and deluges of rain
closed bridges swamped roads and left
some people stranded in their vehicles
meanwhile in california officials are
struggling to contain wildfires that
have destroyed hundreds of buildings and
forced thousands of people to leave
their homes more than a dozen large
wildfires have burned roughly 2
300 square miles of grass brush and
forest lands that are exceptionally dry
due to years of drought
well all this comes as kamala harris is
in singapore the u.s vice president is
visiting the region to discuss issues
including climate change the two
countries are launching the u.s
singapore climate partnership to develop
new environmental standards and
collaborate on projects to expand clean
energy infrastructure development and
improve sustainability
steel is a crucial part of
infrastructure building and development
around the world but producing it has a
huge climate impact well now a way of
making the construction material without
using coal is being developed which
could be crucial to reducing emissions
in the future here's why the solution is
needed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well let's bring in fourstein de la
salle who's a director of the energy
transitions commission uh welcome to you
so just how green is the green steel
that's being trialled at the moment and
is it all purely down to how the steel
plants are powered
it is not only how the steel plant are
powered it's the whole production
process
from the mine to
the final step of refining the steel
that are important to the carbon eyes
and so the technology that has been
tested by ssab now
at an initial scale is very exciting
because it decarbonizes the whole
process
and how close are we to getting green
steel to market then
well we are a step closer now that
multiple technologies are getting
tested at scale by multiple companies
out there most of the major steel
manufacturers
are investing and have announced for
first of a kind plants to test new
technologies that produce zero carbon
steel the problem now is really to
deploy those technologies at scale the
announcements until now have been of a
handful of projects and we have more
than
500 plants around the world that need to
shift to those new technologies so
deployment is going to take time and
it's going to be a major investment
challenge well yes interesting you say a
major investment challenge is there a
cost to moving to green alternatives
there is today uh the green steel that
is produced by by an ssab or by other
producers is at least 50 percent more
expensive than the high carbon steel at
this point in time and if the targets
are to be met at cop 26 the climate
summit at this autumn how important is
it that steel production is decarbonized
it is uh really important that we have
first steps this year as you probably
know we need to reduce uh global
emissions by 50 by 2030 and that's
really the big
challenge for cop 26 this year
steel will be in the harder to abate
sectors to decarbonize it will take more
time to decarbonize a sector like steel
but if the technologies are not
commercially available by 2030 then we
won't be able to deploy them at scale in
the 2030s so what we expect from copter
26 this year is to see the whole steel
value chain the steel manufacturers but
also the the iron ore miners the energy
providers the buyers of steel in the
automotive sector in construction and
equipment uh really joining forces to
find the business models that will work
in the future
foreign thanks very much indeed
now in the latest of our series of
climate diaries we're meeting alex
stewart who co-founded an eco-conscious
luggage brand aiming to reduce the
amount of single-use plastic in airports
and make travel items more sustainable
beginning of 2018 i had almost a meter
of small intestine removed i've been
fairly unwell for about six months
afterwards just spent
some time in intensive care on a
ventilator in an induced coma
and i came to the point where i was like
well if i didn't survive
what would be the three regrets number
one i've never done my own thing or set
up my own business number two i'd never
been in love and number three i'd never
seen england win the world cup
so with the first point in mind i set
about creating 195.
i was fairly fairly unaware of the
plastic problem that we faced on the
planet
um and i think after watching blue
planet two followed by
reading about early pioneers in the uk
people like emily penn and lucy siegel i
really felt compelled to try and make a
positive change we estimate that over
151 million of these single-use clear
plastic bags are distributed at uk
airports every year
to help tackle this we've redesigned the
wash bag to incorporate a reusable and
detachable clear pouch that's designed
to airport security standards research
suggests we've got really good at
switching from single-use plastics
things like coffee cups water bottles
bags for life at the supermarket but
maintaining that routine when you're
traveling is difficult and we want to
help people on the move
[Applause]
well that's everything from us for today
next time how a byproduct from making
paper could be a climate friendly
solution to energy storage you can find
out more tomorrow here on the daily
climate show see you then
[Music]